[Aplausos]
la navegación social está directamente
relacionada con el aumento de la
criminalidad
más allá de datos y estudios que nos lo
demuestran creo que es una idea que
todos podemos compartir el verdadero
reto está en plantearnos cómo esto nos
involucra a cada uno
y para experimentarlo
vamos a poner en práctica un poco
nuestras dotes comunitarias de forma que
os voy a pedir que os toméis de la mano
por favor de hecho mejor si se ponen de
pie para que puedan ustedes mismos
observar a todos los demás y ya que
estamos levantamos las manos para verlas
a ver si muy rápido por aquí por ahí
también parece que si todos vengan no se
sienten no se sienten vamos a dar un
pasito más ahora lo que les voy a pedir
es que miremos atrás adelante ya los
lados y cuando se crucen la mirada con
un vecino le regalen una sonrisa porque
no ya están tomados de la mano nos
andamos conociendo
de hecho si no se conocen se pueden
presentar muy brevemente ya se escuchan
risas un guiño a algún gesto de
complicidad ahora ya sí ya acaban de
presentarse tranquilamente conforme se
sientan cómodos se van sentando y nos
relajamos incluso podemos respirar
profundo
qué tal
si cambio el ánimo un poquito
muy bien pues con este nuevo ánimo les
propongo un viaje en el tiempo
vamos a intentar recordar el primer día
de colegio seguramente muchos no lo
recuerdan no pasa nada
podemos utilizar igual el primer día de
trabajo o una primera cita seguro que
casi todos estábamos por lo menos
nerviosos y es que de forma natural se
nos genera este estado de alerta por el
miedo a lo desconocido no saber cómo
debemos comportarnos o cómo nos van a
tratar sin embargo damos un saltito de
tiempo y todo eso paso disfrutamos la
escuela disfrutamos el trabajo hasta
algunos pues llegando a disfrutar las
citas
pero detengámonos un momento me gustaría
que analizáramos este cambio
esta evolución como la llevamos a cabo
los que tengan buena memoria seguro que
le podemos agradecer esta evolución a
una persona ese desconocido que se
acerca y se presenta sin tener porque
cuando mejor fuiste tú felicidades
o el compañero con el que te tocó
compartir pupitre o un maestro o una
maestra que estuvieron muy atentos
aparece una gracia común una risa
contagiosa y de repente nervios qué
nervios y así de esta forma tan fácil
somos capaces de superar nuestros
nuestros miedos y hasta de olvidarlos
pero no siempre es tan fácil
a los que sean tímidos como yo les ha
pasado y nos seguirá pasando
que a veces somos incapaces de romper
estas dinámicas nos cerramos dejamos de
conocer a la gente de aprender de
evolucionar incluso podemos llegar a ser
no tan felices y no se crean del otro
lado pasa igual el resto de personas
tampoco nos conocen no aprenden lo que
podemos enseñarles y se pierden todo lo
bueno que tenemos si pensamos en el
conjunto de la sociedad resulta que
funciona prácticamente igual dependiendo
de cómo nos comportamos la ciudad
evolucionará hacia un lado o hacia otro
y esto determinará nuestra sensación de
seguridad porque donde nos sentimos
seguros o mejor dicho donde nos sentimos
inseguros en calles como la que tenía en
la primera imagen o como esta
es una imagen un poco terrorífica no
imagino que muy pocos se atreverían a
salir por ahí a pasear alegremente
porque sabemos lo que puede pasar pero
no se preocupen ha habido mucha gente
que ha trabajado en el tema y hay
multitud de soluciones
ahora sí ya podemos olvidarnos del tema
vivir tranquilos probablemente podemos
aprender un poquito de la experiencia de
cuando éramos pequeños
yo creo que igual que cuando éramos
niños seguimos necesitando a los demás
para estar seguros es el pertenecer a
una comunidad lo que nos da esa
sensación de seguridad que al final es
mucho más importante que todas las
soluciones caras simplonas y directas
que son las primeras que aparecen en
todas las ciudades es que la realidad
nos dice que el miedo es un factor común
en todas las ciudades por tomar de
ejemplo a la jara el 80% de las personas
no se sienten seguras en general cuando
andamos por las calles que recorremos
todos los días o el transporte público
es el 74% la gente que se siente
insegura
los que van en su propio carro la mitad
de ellos pero el dato más doloroso es el
del 40 por ciento de la gente que
estando en su propia casa se sienta
inseguro
obviamente estos datos nos pueden
sorprender más o menos pero no son muy
distintos al de otras grandes ciudades
tanto del país como de otros países por
ejemplo cuál es la respuesta que le
damos cada uno
en mi caso imagino que como algunos de
ustedes espero que los menos posibles
he sido asaltado en esta ciudad también
he tenido otras experiencias en otras
ciudades así que no se preocupen no pasa
nada pero tan importante es el hecho
como la forma en la que nosotros
respondemos
no podemos dejar que estos eventos se
conviertan en lo más importante que nos
pasa en la vida y que a partir de ahí
todas las decisiones dependan de este
momento
sino que debemos buscar la forma de
madurar y crecer y aprender de estos
eventos buscando soluciones más sanas y
que al final sean más liberadoras porque
si igual que antes si comenzáramos a
hablar donde nos sentimos seguros cada
uno se le ocurriría un lugar la calle
donde creció un barrio familiar un
edificio y probablemente porque esa ha
sido una de las mejores herramientas de
venta
mucha gente ordinaria para vivir lo más
seguro es un coto un fraccionamiento
cerrado privado sin embargo si seguimos
con los datos resulta que los índices de
asaltos en casas en fraccionamientos
cerrados son mucho más altos de lo que
podríamos esperar
es decir
el vivir detrás de una muralla y con un
cuerpo de seguridad de mayor o menor
confianza pero hay que probablemente ni
conocemos no nos garantiza estar a salvo
y esto se repite igual no sólo en
guadalajara sino en muchas ciudades del
país en los grandes pero también en
países que podríamos pensar que son tan
distintos como eeuu y españa
de hecho hasta ahí existe esta sensación
de que robar en estas casas es fácil se
unen varios factores como es el hecho de
horarios compartidos de los vecinos
horarios registrados pero hay uno que es
el más importante siempre que hay un
evento siempre siempre siempre se le
pregunta al vecino y el vecino nunca vio
nada
claro el problema es que en estos
fraccionamientos el modelo de vida que
se fomenta en la mayoría de casos es el
de tener el menor contacto posible con
los demás y en este contexto no es que
no veamos es que somos incapaces de ver
la diferencia sin embargo esto no lo más
grave los datos más llamativos son
aquellos que están vinculados a la
periferia de las ciudades porque resulta
que cuando yo pongo un muro no sólo
estoy delimitando el interior sino que
al mismo tiempo puedo estar generando
espacios duros inhabitables y finalmente
inseguros para todos los de afuera me
pregunto si alguno se animaría a salir a
pasear alrededor de un fraccionamiento
privado en este punto podemos empezar a
tener algún tipo de respuesta y por
poner una similitud cuál es la
diferencia real entre un muro de un
fraccionamiento como éste y el muro
fronterizo sin embargo
nuestra respuesta puede ser totalmente
distinta dependerá sólo del lado del
muro en el que estamos y bueno tampoco
vamos a decir que toda la delincuencia
está vinculada estos fraccionamientos
cerrados hay muchas zonas de la ciudad y
muchas ciudades que tienen problemas de
mayor y menor índice de delincuencia y
de delincuencia más o menos similar o
muy distinta pero casi siempre hay un
factor común que es la pérdida de tejido
social es decir la relación de siempre
entre las personas y entre las familias
nos decía la periodista jay jay camps
que donde no hay ojos en la calle
no se genera esta vigilancia natural que
se da por el mero hecho de convivir
y entonces desaparece la comunidad y con
ella desaparece la seguridad sin embargo
hay lugar para la esperanza
nosotros como ciudadanos
podemos aportar a la solución trabajando
en comunidad desde las calles
tradicionales a los fraccionamientos de
lujo de las colonias más marginadas a
las zonas hiper desarrolladas pero
siempre entendiendo que las soluciones
no pueden ser parciales ni nacer del
egoísmo sino buscar unas soluciones que
sean en pro de la seguridad para todos
pero sobre todo la seguridad con todos
de modo que te invito cosas muy
sencillas a presentarte a un vecino da
igual que lleves años viviendo en el
mismo lugar nunca es tarde a pasar una
hora de la semana en un parque cerca de
tu casa a recorrer las calles paseando a
parar a quedarte quieto en la banqueta a
conversar a dar los buenos días crear un
grupo de whatsapp vecinal lo que se te
ocurra convive porque nuestra seguridad
depende de ti
[Aplausos]